This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. It used to be that if you wanted to feel what it was like to do something, you had to go out and do it. If your dream was to see the Grand Canyon from a raft, you'd head to the river. If you wanted to gaze up close at the Mona Lisa, you'd go to Paris. If you wanted to know what it felt like to walk hand in hand with a lover on a moonlit night, you'd have to go out and find a partner. wanted to know what it felt like to walk hand in hand with a lover on a moonlit night. You'd have to go out and find a partner.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。过去，如果你想感受做某件事是什么感觉，你必须亲自去做。如果你的梦想是乘木筏看大峡谷，你得去河边。如果你想近距离凝视《蒙娜丽莎》，你得去巴黎。如果你想知道在月夜与爱人手牵手散步是什么感觉，你必须出去找个伴侣。想知道在月夜与爱人手牵手散步是什么感觉。你必须出去找个伴侣。
But something in our culture has changed. As we sit on the couch and eat takeout, we watch kitchen virtuosos whip up gourmet meals from scratch. Turn it over, look at the color. And it just makes the house smell like home to me. And then we watch other people eat meals. So if you were alone on Thanksgiving, I hope you would have your Thanksgiving dinner with me. I mean that literally, there's a popular genre on YouTube.
但我们文化中的某些东西已经变了。当我们坐在沙发上吃外卖时，我们看着厨房里的能工巧匠从零开始制作美食。把它翻过来，看看颜色。这让我觉得家里充满了家的味道。然后我们看着其他人吃饭。所以如果你在感恩节独自一人，我希望你能和我一起吃感恩节晚餐。我是字面意思，YouTube上有一个很受欢迎的流派。
Okay, my mouth's seriously celebrating right now. Well, you just watch other people, binge eat. Okay, I'm starving. I'm starving. There's a lot here. Oh my God. It has never been so easy to bring the world into our living rooms and kitchens and bedrooms.
好吧，我现在满嘴都在欢呼。好吧，你只是看着别人，暴饮暴食。好吧，我快饿死了。我快饿死了。这里有很多东西。哦，天哪。把世界带进我们的起居室、厨房和卧室从未如此简单。
And the world that enters our lives has never looked better. You can get the ocean without the seaweed and sunsets without clouds. You can scale a rock face without the fear of a fall. You can experience love. Rebecca, Joe Kufren, my Becca, will you marry me? Without the risk of rejection. The smiles are bigger.
进入我们生活的世界也从未显得如此美好。你可以拥有没有海藻的海洋和没有云彩的日落。你可以攀登岩壁而不必担心坠落。你可以体验爱。丽贝卡，乔·库夫伦，我的贝卡，你愿意嫁给我吗？而且没有被拒绝的风险。笑容更灿烂了。
The emotions are more spectacular. What? I will be... The risks and rewards seem greater, The miles are bigger. The emotions are more spectacular. One, two, three. The risks and rewards seem greater, even though neither really belonged to us. We're in games! We just got a game! These other lives we've come to inhabit can seem more beautiful, more exciting, more satisfying than anything in our actual lives.
情绪更加壮观。什么？我将……风险和回报似乎更大了，笑容更灿烂了。情绪更加壮观。一，二，三。风险和回报似乎更大，尽管这两者其实都不属于我们。我们在游戏中！我们刚刚得到了一个游戏！我们开始居住的这些其他生活，可能比我们实际生活中的任何事情都更美丽、更令人兴奋、更令人满足。
They come in multiple camera angles with all the boring parts spliced out and all the recipe ingredients pre-chopped in those little prep bowls. I definitely vicariously live through cooking shows. I catch myself spending hours a week watching climbing videos on Instagram. I've even built my own climbing wall but I don't use it. Why? My husband watches a Navy SEAL talk about discipline and hard work while eating cereal at 11 p.m. Today, we're thinking about how many of us are outsourcing our lives to virtual alter regas. We'll hear stories from listeners about the lure of losing ourselves in the worlds of other people. And we ask,
它们以多个摄像机角度呈现，所有无聊的部分都被剪掉了，所有食谱配料都在那些小准备碗里预先切好了。我绝对是通过烹饪节目过着间接的生活。我发现自己每周花几个小时在Instagram上观看攀岩视频。我甚至自己建了一面攀岩墙，但我不用它。为什么？我丈夫在晚上11点吃麦片时，看着一个海豹突击队队员谈论纪律和努力工作。今天，我们正在思考我们中有多少人将自己的生活外包给了虚拟的另一个自我。我们将听到听众讲述迷失在别人世界里的诱惑的故事。我们禁不住要问，
what happens when we do this, when we live through the people on our screens and in our headphones? The delights and the dangers of living vicariously this week on Hidden Brain. In most areas of his life, John Sharp is a doer, not a watcher. He is good with his hands and worked for a while as a carpenter's assistant. So a few years ago, when he bought his first house, he made sure to get one with a garage so he could build a wood shop. It's tiny but he's proud of it. Right now I've got a nice 14-inch bandsaw, a three-horsepower cabinet saw, I've got some festival products which are very high end. One of his most important tools though is YouTube. He teaches himself everything he needs to know by watching instructional videos.
当我们这样做时，当我们通过屏幕上和耳机里的人生活时，会发生什么？本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨间接生活的乐趣与危险。在生活的多数领域里，约翰·夏普是个行动派，而不是旁观者。他心灵手巧，曾做过一段时间的木工助手。因此几年前，当他买下第一栋房子时，他确保买了一间带车库的房子，这样他就可以建造一个木工车间。它很小，但他为此感到自豪。现在我有一台不错的14英寸带锯，一台三马力机柜锯，我还有一些非常高端的费斯托产品。不过他最重要的工具之一是YouTube。他通过观看教学视频自学所有需要了解的知识。
It's his first stop for most of his projects, like the crib he just built for his new bond daughter, and the desk he's been working on for his wife. And I've got, you know, probably three or four projects that are just halfway complete or in the queue, if you will. But John's a sixth grade teacher, and he's usually worn out by the end of the day. And so he's been finding himself spending less time in his shop and more time on his couch just watching those how-to videos. And what I do is I usually use it as a to decompress after work.
这是他进行大多数项目的第一站，比如他刚为新出生的女儿做的小床，以及他一直在为妻子制作的书桌。你知道，我大概有三四个项目只完成了一半，或者说正在排队。但约翰是一名六年级老师，他通常在一天结束时筋疲力尽。因此，他发现自己花在车间里的时间变少了，花在沙发上观看那些操作视频的时间变多了。我通常用它来作为下班后放松的方式。
So I go home, open up YouTube, you know, like the other night I was watching at how to build a barn door, because I'm also building one in my house, and I thought, oh, I just wanna get different ideas. What's going on, everybody? I'm Bruce Ulrich, welcome back. In today's video, I'm gonna show you. And it just becomes like this vortex where I'm just like, oh, there's one cool one.
所以我回家，打开YouTube，你知道的，就像前几天我在看如何建造一扇谷仓门，因为我也在家里建一扇，我想，哦，我只是想获得不同的想法。大家好，我是布鲁斯·乌尔里希，欢迎回来。在今天的视频中，我将向大家展示。然后它就变成了一个漩涡，我就想，哦，这个很酷。
I love sliding doors. I think it's cool. And oh, look, there's a different one. I'll watch that one. I built this out of an embrojemental slab. It's not actually one big slug. And then, you know, it seems like 30 to 45 minutes of pass while I watch videos on, you know, people fixing car engines. Super clean your engine bay. So clean that you'll be able to eat off
我喜欢推拉门。我觉得这很酷。哦，看，还有一个不同的。我要看那个。我是用环保板做这个的。其实不是一整块大板。然后，你知道，在我看关于人们修理汽车发动机的视频时，30到45分钟就这样过去了。超级清洁你的发动机舱。干净到你可以在上面吃饭。
or how to build decks. So we're gonna start out by putting the ledger on the house or how to renovate houses. Hey guys, this is my kitchen And it's just non-stop. It's just I mean I could be on there hours and hours and just I mean on a weekday I'll usually watch on average two hours, but on a weekend if I don't have a lot going on You know, I will watch four to five hours easily in a day At first it's entertaining. There's definitely a pleasure aspect of it at the beginning. But after 45 minutes or so, that feeling of enjoyment goes away.
或者如何建造露台。所以我们将从在房子上安装垫木开始，或者如何翻新房屋。嘿，大家好，这是我的厨房，它简直没完没了。我的意思是，我可以在上面待上几个小时，而且在工作日我通常平均会看两个小时，但如果在周末我没有太多事情要做，你知道的，我一天轻松就能看四到五个小时。起初这很有趣。一开始肯定有一种享受的成分。但大约45分钟后，那种享受的感觉就消失了。
And it's just like guilt, then it totally switches from pleasure to, you know, oh, you lazy ass, why are you sitting here when you could be out there? And as he sits there there watching instead of doing, he feels like he's losing something. When I watch the video, what I think I'm losing is I'm losing the ability to gain the skill. I think I'm tricking my mind to think that, you know, oh, I'm getting that skill, I watch the video,
然后就像是内疚，完全从享受转变为，你知道的，哦，你这个懒骨头，既然你可以出去，为什么还要坐在这里？当他坐在那里观看而不是行动时，他觉得自己在失去某些东西。当我观看视频时，我认为我失去的是获得技能的能力。我觉得我在欺骗自己的思想，认为，哦，我正在掌握那个技能，我看了视频，
I know how to do it. In reality, that's not true. I can watch a 20 minute video and that person has shown in 20 minutes what probably has taken them days to do, and I am losing the time and the skill of practice for myself. So instead of going into my shop and practicing the skill that I've seen or this new technique that I'm interested in, I'll just watch another video. Watching experts do expert things is not a new phenomenon. In the 1700 in his autobiography, it has ever since been a pleasure to see good workmen handle their tools.
我知道该怎么做。现实并非如此。我可以看一个20分钟的视频，而那个人在20分钟内展示的内容可能花了他几天的时间，我正在失去属于自己的练习时间和技能。因此，我不会走进车间练习我看到的技能或我感兴趣的新技术，而是会继续看另一个视频。看着专家做专家的事情并不是一种新现象。18世纪在其自传中，看到优秀的工匠操纵他们的工具一直是一种乐趣。
In 19th century England, spectators watched surgeons dissect corpses, sometimes accompanied by the music of a flute. ["Must be a a little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little little And nearly 3,000 years ago, crowds gathered in a stadium to watch people run, jump, and perform other athletic feats in the ancient Olympic games.
在19世纪的英国，旁观者观看外科医生解剖尸体，有时伴随着长笛音乐。接近3,000年前，人群聚集在体育场里，观看人们在古代奥运会上跑步、跳跃和表演其他运动壮举。
What's different today is that our access to experts has exploded. Never before in human history has it been possible to see so many people display their talents. And never before in human history have so many things counted as talents. I can't remember when I started watching YouTube videos. I think it really started to get popular back when I was in middle school or high school. This is Irene Yeh, a software engineer in Santa Monica, California. Irene is busy.
今天不同的是，我们接触专家的渠道呈爆炸式增长。人类历史上从未有过如此多的人展示他们的才华。人类历史上也从未有过如此多的事物被算作才华。我不记得我是什么时候开始看YouTube视频的。我想它真正开始流行是在我上初中或高中时。这是艾琳·叶，加利福尼亚州圣莫尼卡的软件工程师。艾琳很忙。
She can easily be at work for 10 hours a day. In the morning she wakes up, grabs something quick for breakfast, and she's out the door in about 40 minutes. At night she sometimes doesn't get home until 10. After she's taken a quick shower and had her dinner delivered, she often wanders over to YouTube and pulls up a video of someone else's bedtime routine.
她一天工作10个小时是很常见的事。早上她醒来，随便吃点早餐，大约40分钟后就出门了。晚上她有时直到10点才到家。洗了个快澡并叫了外卖晚餐后，她经常闲逛到YouTube上，点开一个别人睡前日常的视频。
And for a while, she enters an alternate reality. Hey guys, so for today's video, I'm gonna be showing you my nighttime routine to de-stress and relax after a long day at work. I usually stop. These videos are people, mostly girls, take of themselves, showing how they come home from work. So when I come home, the very first thing that I do
有一段时间，她进入了一个交替的现实。嘿，大家好，所以今天的视频中，我要向大家展示我漫长的工作日后减压和放松的夜间日常。我通常会停下来。这些视频是人们（主要是女孩）自己拍摄的，展示他们下班回家后的情景。所以当我回家时，我做的第一件事
is I take off my outside shoes and I put on my house shoes. They make dinner and I always like to have some sort of high protein, vegan option mixed with a They unwind and go to bed. I fluff my pillows, I pull back the sheets, not sleeping with the comforter. So I just slept with them. And I usually get a really good night's sleep after doing this routine. I genuinely sleep like a baby. So I hope that you guys, I...
就是脱掉外面的鞋子，换上居室鞋。他们做晚餐，我总是喜欢把某种高蛋白的纯素选项混合在他们放松并上床睡觉的过程中。我拍松枕头，拉开床单，不盖羽绒被睡。所以我只是盖着它们睡。做完这套日常后，我通常能睡个好觉。我真的像个婴儿一样入睡。所以我希望你们，我……
Irene suspects these women don't actually live like this. But she doesn't mind the Artifice. She herself doesn't have the bandwidth right now to make side dishes or exfoliate. She'd rather watch someone else do those things and for a few minutes escape into another person's life. It's cheaper, it's simpler, and the emotional results close enough. Honestly watching these people do all the hard work and make up their perfect license, it's like a lot easier for me to get a taste of what this type of life could be,
艾琳怀疑这些人其实并不这样生活。但她并不介意这种虚假。她自己现在没有精力去制作配菜或去角质。她宁愿看别人做这些事情，然后在几分钟内逃到另一个人的生活中。这更便宜、更简单，而且情感上的结果也足够接近。老实说，看着这些人做所有的苦工并编造出他们完美的生活，这让我更容易体会到这种生活可能会是什么样子，
while I lounge in my amapid and eating my Chinese takeout. in my amapered and eating my Chinese takeout. Living vicariously makes us feel like we have the things we want, even when we can't have them. It's a substitute for the real lives we lead and for the things we lack in those lives. Living through others also fills even deeper needs. It can fill the holes in our psychological lives and serve as a self-esteem pick me up. A listener from Florida shared a story with us along these lines. She requested that we only use her first name in order to protect her privacy. Okay, I'm Natalie. I live in Miami. Right now I'm working in human resources.
同时我躺在扶手椅上吃着我的中餐外卖。在扶手椅上吃着我的中餐外卖。间接生活让我们觉得自己拥有想要的东西，即使我们无法拥有它们。它是我们真正生活以及生活中所缺乏的事物的替代品。通过他人生活也满足了更深层次的需求。它能填补我们心理生活中的空白，并起到重塑自尊的作用。一位来自佛罗里达州的听众向我们分享了一个这方面的故事。为了保护隐私，她要求我们只使用她的名字。好吧，我是娜塔莉。我住在迈阿密。现在我从事人力资源工作。
Natalie is 23 years old and says she was always on the quiet side. She had a rough time in high school and withdrew into herself. High school and I guess all of primary school, you know, before I went to college was kind of hard for me. I was very quiet, a little insecure. Natalie felt she was overweight. She got bullied. She was interested in music and singing, but her low self-esteem meant she rarely put herself out there.
娜塔莉今年23岁，说自己一直是个比较安静的人。她在高中时过得很艰难，并封闭了自己。高中，我想还有整个小学，你知道的，在我上大学之前对我来说有点艰难。我很安静，有点不自信。娜塔莉觉得自己超重了。她被霸凌了。她对音乐和唱歌很感兴趣，但低自尊意味着她很少表现自己。
So, you know, I never really tried to get feedback, because I was afraid of getting a bad response. Her family would sometimes notice her drifting off into her own world. They would always say, not only what are you thinking about because I would just be staring off into space going on little tangents in my mind. One time Natalie was with an aunt on a cruise. She was staring off into the distance, lost her thought for more than an hour. And she finally asked me, what are you thinking about?
所以，你知道的，我从不真正试图获得反馈，因为我害怕得到不好的回应。她的家人有时会注意到她陷入自己的世界。他们总是会问，娜塔莉，你在想什么，因为我只会凝视着太空，在脑海中做着小小的离题。有一次娜塔莉和姑姑在游轮上。她凝视着远方，走神了一个多小时。她终于问我，你在想什么？
And I was thinking about a TV show that I had been watching, just like imagining myself being on the production set or something like that. Everybody quiet, officer, cut. Why did the others? Over the years, as new forms of technology sprang up around her, Natalie found new solutions to the missing pieces in her life. She takes out her phone and opens Instagram to a photo of a woman with long, brown hair.
我在想我一直在看的一个电视节目，想象自己身处制片现场之类的。大家安静，警官，卡。为什么其他人？多年来，随着周围涌现出各种新技术，娜塔莉为生活中的缺失部分找到了新的解决方案。她掏出手机，打开Instagram，看着一张长棕发女子的照片。
She has a long sleeve top tucked into some high-waisted shorts. She looks like she's in really, really good shape. Her makeup is perfect. And when I see her outfit, it's beautiful. And I know that I would never even think to put those clothing items together. Like I could never, you know, put an outfit that stylish together. I asked her why she felt that trendy outfits were not for her in real life. I still, you know, feel like that little girl sometimes and I don't want to stand out. I don't want to bring too much attention to myself. Other times, Natalie Thumbs through Pinterest. I have like folders for each of the rooms in my home. It's almost like I can go into my Pinterest bedroom
她穿一件塞进高腰短裤的长袖上衣。她看起来状态非常非常好。她的妆容完美。当我看到她的穿搭时，太美了。我知道我甚至不会想到把这些衣服搭配在一起。就像我永远不可能，你知道的，把一套这么时髦的衣服搭配在一起。我问她为什么觉得潮流穿搭在现实生活中不适合她。我有时仍然，你知道的，觉得自己像个小女孩，我不想引人注目。我不想给自己招惹太多注意力。有时，娜塔莉会浏览Pinterest。我有为家里每个房间建的文件夹。这几乎就像我可以走进我的Pinterest卧室
and see my beautiful bed and the sheets are very expensive. So I have one called my first home. I have one called beauty. I have one for my wedding that's coming up. I have one for do-it-yourself projects, which I have never attempted. Natalie drives more than an hour to work each way five days a week. Along the way she listens to music.
看到我美丽的床，床单非常昂贵。所以我有一个文件夹叫我的第一个家。我有一个叫美丽。我有一个为即将到来的婚礼准备的。我有一个用于我从未尝试过的DIY项目。娜塔莉每周五天，单程开车一个多小时去上班。一路上她听着音乐。
Actually, listening doesn't quite describe what she does. And when I listen to music I'm always the musician. Like I'll be singing in my head. And I'll even like start the song over if I missed my favorite part because I want to see myself singing the best part of the song. So I'll make fun of myself that I can listen to the same song 50 times just to get it right in my fake performance. Give me an example of the kind of song that's happened the last time too.
其实，听并不能准确描述她的所作所为。当我听音乐时，我总是音乐家。就像我在脑海里唱歌一样。如果我错过了最喜欢的部分，我甚至会把歌重新放一遍，因为我想看到自己唱出歌曲最精彩的部分。所以我常常拿自己开玩笑，我可以把同一首歌听50遍，只为了在我的假表演中把它唱对。给我举个上次发生这种事的歌的例子。
Oh my god. Tiny dancer by Elton John this morning. Natalie imagines herself singing and playing the piano. I'm a great musician in my head. I play every instrument. I can sing any song. And there's something else. This is so embarrassing, but I want somebody else to be watching me. Like, I'll kind of be performing it in my head in front of an audience. I'm an amazing man.
哦，天哪。今天早上埃尔顿·约翰的《小舞者》。娜塔莉想象自己唱歌和弹钢琴。我在脑海里是个伟大的音乐家。我演奏每一种乐器。我能唱任何歌。还有一件事。这太尴尬了，但我希望有人看着我。就像，我会在观众面前在脑海里表演它。我是一个了不起的人。
In the audience, I see my parent. I'll think, okay, well, I want my best friend there, so then I'll focus on what my best friend would look like in the audience watching on the highway. Of course, you wouldn't be able to spot Natalie the magnetic performer if you passed Natalie the driver on the highway. No, if you looked at me, I would look completely normal. Ten and two on the steering wheel. She scrolls to her phone and pulls up a duet,
在观众席里，我看到了我的父母。我会想，好吧，我希望我最好的朋友在那里，然后我会专注于我最好的朋友在高速公路旁边的观众席上会是什么样子。当然，如果你在高速公路上经过驾驶娜塔莉的你，是绝对认不出这位魅力四射的表演者的。不，如果你看着我，我会看起来完全正常。双手放在方向盘的十点和两点钟位置。她滑动手机，点出一个二重唱视频，
featuring Bradley Cooper and Lady Gaga. Are you tired trying to fill that void? Or do you need more? I'm falling And all the good times I find myself falling For change And all the bad times I hear myself I'm on the deep end, what just I can't hit the nose that she's hitting right now.
由布莱德利·库珀和Lady Gaga主演。你是否厌倦了试图填补那个空白？还是你需要更多？我正在下坠，在所有美好的时光里，我发现自己为了改变而下坠，在所有糟糕的时光里，我听到自己……我在深渊边缘，刚刚发生了什么，我唱不出她现在正在唱的那些高音。
I asked Natalie what she thought these daydreams were doing for her. It almost feels like it's filling a void that I haven't been able to fill ever since in high school. That was the closest I ever came to being a musician. Natalie's fiancé bought her a guitar after she told him her dream of being a performer. The instrument has mostly sat unused. The daydream versions, the ones on her phone, those versions are so much better. Watching or hearing someone else do things makes Natalie feel good, but only for a moment. Yeah, well, I mean, when you're watching them do it on TV, it just, it looks so easy and nobody
我问娜塔莉，她觉得这些白日梦对她有什么帮助。这感觉就像是在填补我自高中以来一直无法填补的空白。那是我有生以来最接近成为音乐家的一次。娜塔莉的未婚夫在她表达了成为表演者的梦想后给她买了一把吉他。这把乐器大部分时间都闲置着。白日梦里的版本，手机上的那些版本，要好得多。看别人或听别人做事会让娜塔莉感觉很好，但只是一会儿。是的，我的意思是，当你在电视上看着他们做这件事时，它看起来太简单了，而且没有人
talks about how hard it is. And, you know, I think that's also why it makes people feel so bad about themselves because, you know, this person on TV, it's so easy for them. Why is it so hard for me to get these things done? What's wrong with me? Many of us have experienced what Natalie is feeling, a mix of emotions as we watch others perform difficult tasks with ease. We find it inspiring and we find it deflating. Coming up, the quirk in our heads that makes watching others so compelling. I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain. This is NPR. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
谈论它是多么困难。而且，你知道，我认为这也是为什么它让人对自己感觉这么糟糕的原因，因为，你知道，电视上的这个人，这对他们来说太容易了。为什么我把这些事情做好这么难？我怎么了？我们许多人都体验过娜塔莉的感受，当我们看着别人轻松完成困难任务时，心中交织着各种情绪。我们既感到受鼓舞，又感到受打击。接下来，我们将探讨我们脑海中使观看他人变得如此引人入胜的那个怪癖。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。这里是NPR。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Hello, I'm Bob Ross. If this is your first time with us, let me extend a personal invitation if you'd drag out your little paint brushes and some paints and paint along with us each show. Tell you what, let's get right to it. If you happen to watch public television in the 80s and 90s, you may have come across the painter, Bob Ross. And let that knife just float. Let it have come across the painter, Bob Ross. And let that knife just float, let it float right down the side of the mountain. Think about where light would strike.
你好，我是鲍勃·罗斯。如果这是你第一次和我们在一起，让我发出诚挚的邀请，请你拉出你小小的画笔和一些颜料，在每个节目中和我们一起画画。跟你说吧，我们直接开始吧。如果你碰巧看过80年代和90年代的公共电视台，你可能遇到过画家鲍勃·罗斯。让那把刀浮动。让它遇到过画家鲍勃·罗斯。让那把刀浮动，让它顺着山坡浮动下来。想想光线会照在哪里。
With his gentle voice, kind eyes, and halo of brown hair, he made you feel, soon, got to make his little noises or it doesn't work right. That you could absolutely learn, how to paint like a master. Just pull. See, they're not easy that is, so take a little blue, a little tiny bit of blue. Edelbrayan knows why so many Americans fell in love with Bob Ross, and why they felt after watching him,
凭借他温柔的声音、善良的眼神和一头棕色的卷发，他让你感到——马上，得发出他那种小声音，否则就不对劲——你绝对可以学会如何像大师一样画作。只要拉。看，它们并不容易，所以拿一点蓝色，一点点蓝色。Edelbrayan知道为什么这么多美国人爱上鲍勃·罗斯，以及为什么他们在看完他之后感到
just let your imagination take it anywhere you want to go. That they could be painters too. You could also hear in that clip just the warmth and encouragement. I really, you really are kind of inspired to jump right in and try yourself. It is a behavioral scientist at the University of Chicago's Bootschool of Business. Along with colleague Michael Cardis, he studies mental simulation. What we think a new experience will feel like. One thing we find is that, you know, instructional videos, other videos you can pull up on YouTube.
只要让你的想象力带你去任何你想去的地方。他们也可以成为画家。你也可以从那段音频中听到温暖和鼓励。我真的，你真的有点受到启发，想要直接跳进去自己尝试一下。他是芝加哥大学布斯商学院的行为科学家。他和同事迈克尔·卡迪斯一起研究心理模拟。我们认为一次新体验会是什么感觉。我们发现的一件事是，你知道，教学视频，你可以在YouTube上调出的其他视频。
They teach you something, so they tell you objective details about that experience. But viewers come away thinking that those things have taught them everything. And that discrepancy is at the core of what we're interested in here. Did you and Michael ever experience this yourselves? For sure, I mean, you know, as a consumer myself, you know, at the sports end of things, interested in here. Did you and Michael ever experience this yourselves? For sure, I mean, as a consumer myself, at the sports end of things, you can catch yourself screaming at the TV, why did the quarterback not make that throw?
它们教给你一些东西，所以它们告诉你关于那次体验的客观细节。但观众离开时却认为这些东西已经教会了他们一切。这种差异正是我们这里感兴趣的核心。你和迈克尔有没有亲身经历过这种情况？当然，我的意思是，你知道，作为一个消费者，你知道，在体育方面，对这里感兴趣。你和迈克尔有没有亲身经历过这种情况？当然，我的意思是，作为一个消费者，在体育方面，你会发现自己在朝电视大喊，为什么四分卫不那样传球？
Kind of catching myself wondering, it's probably a lot harder in real life than I think about sitting on this couch. So certainly, experiences like that. And also for my professional life, you know, when I started as a professor here a few years ago, one major part of the job is teaching. And one thing we do here at the University of Chicago is have new professors sit in on a class. So I spent a whole quarter watching someone else teach before I then
我有点发现自己想知道，在现实生活中可能比我坐在沙发上想的要困难得多。所以当然有这样的经历。对于我的职业生涯也是如此，你知道的，几年前我刚在这里开始担任教授时，工作的一个主要部分就是教学。我们在芝加哥大学做的一件事就是让新教授旁听一门课。所以我花了整整一个季度的时间看别人教书，然后
the next quarter jumped in and taught. And that was also an interesting learning experience for me. After 10 weeks of watching someone, you kind of feel pretty confident. I've invested a lot of time and effort into this. And then the next quarter rolls around and I'm the one in the suit now standing in front of the room and all the eyes are on me.
下一个季度才跳进去开始教书。对我来说这也是一段有趣的学。经历。经过10周的观察，你觉得自己相当有信心。我在其中投入了大量的时间和精力。然后下一个季度到了，现在轮到我穿着西装站在房间前面，所有的目光都聚焦在我身上。
And I quickly realized it's a lot easier to watch somebody do something than it is to actually do it yourself. So also in the professional world, kind of learning through getting a taste of experience, you often realize how much harder things are in practice. It's interesting because as you talk, I'm reminded of the very common experience that many of us have watching people who are very good at doing things, which is they do make it
我很快意识到，看别人做一件事比自己实际去做要容易得多。所以在职业世界里，通过品尝经验来学习，你经常会发现在实践中事情要困难得多。这很有趣，因为当你说话时，我想起了我们许多人都有的一个非常普遍的经历，那就是看着那些非常擅长做事的人，他们确实把事情做成了
look easy. You watch a chef chopping vegetables or you watch a musician playing the piano and people who've been doing things for a long time, there is not just a skill and an excellence in what they do, but there's an effortlessness in what they do. And you pick up on that and you say, all I have to do is sit before the piano and let my fingers relax and surely I can play Mozart too. I find that very interesting. This idea that making it look easy, we might have a hard time appreciating expertise. We can have underappreciate what other people are performing, what other experts are doing
看起来很简单。你看着厨师切菜，或者看着音乐家弹钢琴，那些长期做这些事情的人，他们所做的不只是技巧和卓越，他们所做的事情中有一种毫不费力。你注意到了这一点，然后你说，我所要做的就是坐在钢琴前，让我的手指放松，我肯定也能弹奏莫扎特。我觉得这非常有趣。这种认为它看起来很简单，我们可能很难欣赏专业知识的想法。我们可能会低估其他人正在表演的东西，其他专家正在为我们做的事情，
for us, technicians that fix things for us, athletes that perform for us. The best of them, ironically, make it seem like it's the easiest possible performance from an observer's perspective. So I am really interested in that discrepancy. Do we kind of struggle to fully appreciate the talents of others? Ed wanted to test the hypothesis that watching experts perform a skill, watching them over and over again, improves people's confidence, but not their ability. So he came up with some clever experiments. In one of them, he had 400 volunteers watch an instructional video
为我们修理东西的技术人员，为我们表演的运动员。讽刺的是，他们当中最好的人，从旁观者的角度来看，让它看起来像是最简单的表演。所以我真的对这种差异很感兴趣。我们是否有点难以完全欣赏别人的才华？Ed想要测试这样一个假设：观看专家展示一项技能，一遍又一遍地观看，可以提高人们的信心，但不能提高他们的能力。所以他想出了一些聪明的实验。其中一个实验中，他让400名志愿者观看教学视频
to learn how to do the tablecloth trick. Three, two, one, heart. And the crowd goes wild! Thank you! It's that magic trick where you pull a tablecloth out from underplates and silverware without disturbing anything on the table. Ed had lots of videos to choose from on YouTube. I've got both plates, cups and saucers, do you like a cup of coffee? Well, thank you.
来学习如何做桌布戏法。三，二，一，拉。人群沸腾了！谢谢！那是那个魔术，你把桌布从盘子和银器下面抽出来，而不会打扰桌子上的任何东西。Ed在YouTube上有许多视频可供选择。我既有盘子、杯子和茶托，你想喝杯咖啡吗？好的，谢谢。
Many videos talk you through the trick, step by step. Step 5. Pull the cloths straight down toward the ground. Pull quickly and with confidence, so that the tablecloth slides out from under the dishes and cups. Ed wanted to test the effects of learning through watching. So he found a nearly silent video where a bearded science teacher demonstrates the magic trick for students.
许多视频一步一步地教你这个戏法。第五步。把桌布笔直向下拉向地面。迅速而自信地拉，以便桌布从盘子和杯子下面滑出来。Ed想测试通过观看学习的效果。所以他找到了一段几乎无声的视频，视频中一个留着胡子的科学老师向学生演示了这个魔术。
The teacher's hands bob up and down as he holds the ends of a tablecloth, and he concentrates on three bowls and some silverware. Then he pulls the tablecloth, the dishes and silverware barely move. It's all over in less than 15 seconds. Nothing to it, right? I'm interested in that video because on the surface it's such a hard task. Anybody should recognize that this is a really complicated thing to pull off. It doesn't matter if I just watched a video 20 times. This is really, really hard if I've never tried it before.
老师拿着桌布的两端，双手上下晃动，注意力集中在三个碗和一些银制餐具上。然后他拉动桌布，盘子和银器几乎没有动。这一切在不到15秒内就结束了。没什么难的，对吧？我对那个视频很感兴趣，因为表面上这是一个如此困难的任务。任何人都应该意识到这是一个非常复杂的把戏。即使我刚刚把视频看了20遍也没用。如果我以前从没试过，这真的非常非常难。
We thought this was going to be a conservative test of the hypothesis that, of course, merely watching a video shouldn't make me better off. This is something that I'm going to have to practice a bunch of times. And yet we find that if you watch this video 20 times, for example, and we specifically ask you, imagine you jump in right now with no other practice than what you've just had, how well would you do on your very first attempt? You jump in and try to pull the tablecloth out. And if you've watched a bunch of times, you think you could pull it off, which I find rather surprising because of how obviously complicated that skill is. I would find it very unlikely that participants can pull it off merely from watching the video many times.
我们认为这将是对这个假设的一个保守测试：当然，仅仅观看视频并不能让我变得更好。这是我必须练习很多次的技能。然而我们发现，如果你把这个视频看上20遍，例如，我们专门问你：想象一下，除了刚才的经验之外没有任何其他练习，你现在就上场，在第一次尝试中你会表现得怎么样？你上场试图把桌布抽出来。如果你看了很多遍，你会觉得自己能成功，我觉得这相当令人惊奇，因为这项技能显然非常复杂。我认为参与者仅仅通过多次观看视频是不太可能成功的。
And you found in fact that there was in some way sort of a dose effect relationship, the more times people watch the video, the more they watched it, the more they felt they could do it themselves. Exactly. And what's especially interesting there is we compared that exposure to other kinds of training you could do. So we had people watching videos and the more that they watched videos, the more confident they became. But this wasn't true for other kinds of training.
事实上你发现某种程度上存在一种剂量效应关系，人们看视频的次数越多，他们看得越多，就越觉得他们自己能做到。绝对是的。特别有趣的是，我们把这种接触与其他类型的培训进行了比较。我们让人们观看视频，他们看视频越多，他们就越自信。但这对于其他类型的培训并不成立。
So if we had people spend more time just thinking about the trick or spend more time reflecting on the trick or spending more time reading written instructions about how to about the trick or spend more time reflecting on the trick or spending more time reading written instructions about how to do the trick, more time didn't lead people to be more confident. So there seems to be something special about having lots of practice with videos above and beyond other kinds of practice. In other words to summarize what you were saying, reading about the skill does not seem to communicate the same transfer of expertise than merely watching someone perform the skill.
因此，如果我们让人们花更多时间只是思考这个戏法，或者花更多时间反思这个戏法，或者花更多时间阅读关于如何做这个戏法的书面说明，花更多时间并没有让人们更有信心。因此，除了其他类型的练习之外，通过视频进行大量练习似乎有一些特殊之处。换句话说，总结你的话，阅读这项技能似乎并没有像仅仅看某人表演这项技能那样传达同等水平的专业知识转移。
Exactly. Watching seems intimately connected to our perceptions that we're learning. Now, now please tell me that with the tablecloth experiment you actually had beginner stand before tablecloth and actually yank the tablecloth out. Please tell me that actually did happen. I am very regrettably informing you that we did not run that condition, but I think I will after this discussion. You'd have to invest a fair amount in new China, I'm guessing. We would, we would.
绝对是的。观看似乎与我们正在学习的感知息息相关。现在，请告诉我，在桌布实验中，你真的让初学者站在桌布前，把桌布猛地抽出来了吗？请告诉我这真的发生了。我很遗憾地通知大家，我们没有进行那个条件测试，但我认为讨论完之后我会做的。我猜你必须在新的瓷器上投入相当多的资金。我们会，我们会。
I mean, we did try to bottle this in a more fun way, so not exactly with the dishes, but we have this moonwalk experiment. And slide the left leg back and then switch. And so this is the instructional video that we had participants watch a clip of that was supposedly going to try to train them. This is exactly how you do the moonwalk. You're going to slide the left leg back and you're going to switch weights.
我的意思是，我们确实试图以一种更有趣的方式来实现这一点，不完全用盘子，但我们做了这个太空步实验。然后把左脚向后滑，然后切换。这就是我们让参与者观看的一段剪辑的教学视频，据说它将试图训练他们。这就是你做太空步的确切方法。你要把左脚向后滑，你要转换重心。
So the right leg goes down, you push the left back. When you're pushing the left leg back, keep it flat on the ground. Switch, switch, switch. All right guys, here we go. One music. Five, six, five, six, seven, go. One, two, three, four. But again, the key thing that we're interested in is, you know, once you're actually trying those
所以右脚落地，你把左脚向后推。当你把左脚向后推时，保持它平贴在地面上。切换，切换，切换。好了，各位，我们开始吧。音乐。五，六，五，六，七，走。一，二，三，四。但同样，我们感兴趣的关键是，你知道，一旦你真正尝试这些
steps, it turns out there's also some internal reactions and feelings and emotions and nerves that make it harder than it seems. So in this study what we did was we took this same exact instructional video and participants either watched it once or watched it 20 times. So again, this is our key manipulation here, getting people lots of exposure to video watching, how does that affect their perceptions of learning, and how does that affect their actual learning. So we told them to imagine that there was a panel of judges who would then watch them perform the moonwalk once across the screen, and they were going to judge how well they performed the moonwalk.
步骤，事实证明，也有一些内在的反应、感觉、情绪和紧张，使得它比看起来更难。所以在这次研究中，我们做的是使用完全相同的教学视频，让参与者要么看一次，要么看20遍。所以再次强调，这是我们的关键操作，让人们大量接触视频观看，这如何影响他们对学习的感知，以及这如何影响他们的实际学习。所以我们告诉他们想象有一个评委团，然后会看他们表演一次太空步，穿过屏幕，他们将评判他们太空步表演得有多好。
And we asked them to predict, what do you think, what score do you think you're going to get based on your performance? Then what we did was set up a video camera and participants actually then made an attempt at the Moonwalk. These are very, very fun videos to watch. We have a whole battery of these things in our research library. And truth be told, we showed them to a panel of judges. So the judges had no idea whether this performer had watched the video once or watched the video 20 times. In fact, both sets of participants, whether you watched once or 20 times, didn't do very well.
然后我们要求他们预测，你觉得怎么样，根据你的表现你觉得自己会得到什么分数？接着我们架设了一台摄像机，参与者随后真正尝试了一次太空步。这些是非常非常有趣的视频。我们的研究库里有一整套这些东西。说实话，我们把它们展示给了一个评委团。所以评委们完全不知道这个表演者是只看了一次视频还是看了20遍。事实上，两组参与者，无论你看了一次还是20遍，都表现得不是很好。
But again, the key insight here, if you watched 20 times, you thought you were going to kind of win that performance. When, in fact, you performed no better than other participants. This is what we are doing right now. I have no idea how to do that. That's what I was going to do. God, awful. I can't find out. Of course. Of course.
但再次强调，这里的关键见解是，如果你看了20遍，你会觉得自己会在这次表演中获胜。而事实上，你的表现并不比其他参与者更好。这就是我们现在正在做的事情。我不知道该怎么做。这就是我要做的。天哪，太糟糕了。我找不出来。当然。当然。
So these are our participants actually trying their moonwalk attempts. And it's great in some of these videos, as you can hear, are kind of verbalizing the difficulties of doing this task. They jump in and they start to try to emulate what they saw in that video, move the right foot back, move the left foot forward, and it turns out they're literally verbalizing how difficult it is.
所以这些是我们的参与者实际尝试太空步的画面。很棒的是，在其中一些视频中，正如你所听到的，他们把完成这项任务的困难诉诸言表。他们跳进去，开始尝试模仿他们在视频中看到的内容，把右脚向后移，把左脚向前移，结果他们真的用语言表达了这项任务有多么困难。
Good. I don't know if I'm doing it, but this is better than you go get for me today. And again, what's especially interesting for us is some of them told us before they made that attempt they're really going to do it well. They're going to nail this attempt. And only in the act of trying to realize oh I guess I didn't learn nearly as much as I thought just from watching that video. When this happens, do you think it changes the way people watch the next videos? Does it possibly once you learn that your overconfidence
好。我不知道我有没有做到，但这比你今天为我做的要好。同样，对我们来说特别有趣的是，其中一些人在尝试之前告诉我们，他们真的会做好的。他们这次一定会成功。只有在尝试的过程中，他们才意识到，哦，我猜我从观看那个视频中学到的东西远没有我想象的那么多。当这种情况发生时，你认为它会改变人们观看下一个视频的方式吗？一旦你了解到你的过度自信在一个视频中是没有根据的，它是否可能成为你在观看下一个视频时防范过度自信的护盾？我确实认为考虑这种可能性很有趣：那些满怀信心冲进去的人，结果却惨遭失败。这和你以为的自己与发现的自己之间存在着相当大的差距。
was not warranted in one video, do you believe that it's a guard against overconfidence when you watch the next video? I do think it's interesting to consider the possibility that people who jump in and they're really, really confident and it turns out they fail miserably. That's a pretty big gap between who you thought you were and who you find out you are.
我怀疑对于一些参与者来说，这是有动力作用的，他们会意识到，好吧，我得在这个上面投入更多的练习。但我不知道对于许多人来说，这是否只是打击了积极性。感知与现实之间的巨大差距让他们觉得，好吧，我毕竟不是干这块料。
And I suspect that for some participants, that's motivating and they realize, okay, I'm gonna have to invest a lot more practice into this. But I wonder if for a lot of people, that's just demotivating. That the giant gap between perceptions and reality leads them to think, well, I'm not meant for this task after all.
I'm never going to pick up this ability. And so they don't practice again. And that's something I'd love to keep researching. But I do think that's a very real possibility from this effect. How do you balance the idea that in some ways, you know, watching people who are very good at doing something can be a source of inspiration for us. You know, you watch LeBron James playing basketball and you're motivated to go out and try and
我永远也学不会这个技能。于是他们就不再练习了。这是我很想继续研究的课题。但我确实认为，这种效应带来的这种可能性是非常真实的。你如何看待这样一种观点：在某些方面，你知道，看那些非常擅长某事的人做一件事，可以成为我们的灵感来源。你看勒布朗·詹姆斯打篮球，你就会有动力去球场尝试
play basketball yourself because what he does is beautiful and it's beautiful to watch. How do you balance that with the fact that when you actually get to the court having watched LeBron James, you might now be more disinclined to pursue basketball as a sport and in fact just retire to watching LeBron James on the couch. That's right. I mean, I think it's really important for learners and people in general as we're trying to pick up new skills to have a longer term mindset in place. So I think if you have that mindset kind of in place,
亲自打篮球，因为他的动作很美，而且看他打球也是一种享受。你如何平衡这一点：当你真的看过勒布朗·詹姆斯打球后去了球场，你现在反而可能更不愿意把篮球当作一项运动去追求，事实上甚至退缩到在沙发上看勒布朗·詹姆斯打球。确实如此。我的意思是，我认为对于学习者和普通人来说，当我们试图掌握新技能时，树立长远的心态真的很重要。所以我觉得如果你有了那种心态，
it's good to feel inspired by experts that we watch around us. Like I said earlier, it's helpful to kind of inspire action, maybe overconfidence is a good thing in some sense because it gets us off the couch and thinking we can do these things ourselves. I think that is good as long as we realize, right, first time failure doesn't mean something longer term about me. It's the fact that merely watching wasn't enough.
从我们身边的专家身上感到受启发是一件好事。就像我刚才说的，这有助于激发行动，也许在某种意义上过度自信是一件好事，因为它能让我们离开沙发，认为我们自己也能做这些事情。我认为只要我们意识到，好吧，第一次失败并不意味着关于我自身的长远问题，这只是说明仅仅观看是不够的。
So now that I'm actually on the playing field, now that I've actually made an attempt and failed, hopefully if people have that long-term mindset in place, they realize that they should stay here and kind of have more real-time experiences that they're going to be in it for the long haul. We only see LeBron James making that awesome dunk in the championship. LeBron for the time! When we think of, maybe I could do that too. Maybe I have that inside of me. When in fact so many other things, years of situations
所以现在我真正踏上了球场，现在我真正尝试过并且失败了，希望如果人们具备那种长远的心态，他们就会意识到他们应该留在这里，进行更多实时体验，他们会为此长期坚持下去。我们只看到勒布朗·詹姆斯在总决赛中完成那个精彩的扣篮。勒布朗，永远的神！当我们想到，也许我也能做到。也许我的体内也有这种潜能。但事实上，还有很多其他事情，多年的种种情况
and experience went in to allowing Lebron James to show that final product. This Lebron goes one on one, pull the pads, one bullet under, pull the pads. Ed wanted to know if there was a way to keep people from falling prey to the illusion of overconfidence. So before someone tries to replicate a feat they see on YouTube, is there a way to remind them that it's more complicated than they think? To test this, Ed had three groups of volunteers watch a short video of someone juggling with bowling pins and
和经验才造就了勒布朗·詹姆斯最终呈现的成果。这个勒布朗单打，急停跳投，防守反击，急停跳投。埃德想知道有没有办法让人类不再沦为过度自信幻觉的牺牲品。所以在人们试图模仿他们在YouTube上看到的绝技之前，有没有办法提醒他们事情比想象中更复杂？为了测试这一点，埃德让三组志愿者看了一段关于玩保龄球瓶杂耍的短视频，
then told everyone that they would be asked to juggle too. He gave each group different kinds of information about juggling, like the weight and dimensions of a bowling pin. But in one group, he had volunteers actually hold a bowling pin for one minute. They didn't juggle it, they just held it. Would giving people this tiny taste of juggling make them better at predicting how difficult the task would be? The answer was yes. All someone needed was that one minute of direct access into the first step of juggling.
然后告诉所有人他们也会被要求进行杂耍。他向每组提供关于杂耍的不同信息，比如保龄球瓶的重量和尺寸。但在其中一组中，他让志愿者实际拿住一个保龄球瓶一分钟。他们没有用它杂耍，只是拿着。给人们这种对杂耍的微小体验，会让他们更擅长预测这项任务有多困难吗？答案是肯定的。每个人只需要亲身体验杂耍第一步的那一分钟。
That seems to be enough to remind people, oh yeah, it's not just about holding my hand here and it's not just about this angle, but when I do those things, there's weight involved. There's these physiological reactions that I'm having as I'm performing this trick that will likely make it a little bit harder than I feel it is just from watching. So one big take home from that study is to try to combine instructional video learning with some form of real-world practice. So even if you're just kind of mimicking along at home holding objects, right, it may not be the bowling pin in the video, but holding a weighted object as you're watching this
这似乎足以提醒人们，哦对，这不仅仅是把手放在这里，也不仅仅是关于这个角度，而是当我做这些动作时，是有重量参与的。我在表演这个绝技时产生的这些生理反应，很可能会让它比我仅仅通过观看时感觉到的要难一些。所以这项研究的一个重要启示，就是尝试将教学视频学习与某种形式的现实世界练习结合起来。所以即使你只是在家里拿着物品跟着模仿，好吧，可能不是视频里的保龄球瓶，但当你看着这个
thing should presumably make you much better off at appreciating the skills complexity than if you were just merely watching. Why do you think it is that merely sort of getting people in some ways out of their heads and into their bodies seems to provide some kind of buffer or protection against this overconfidence? Mental simulation just isn't built to incorporate kind of physiological reactions in eternal states. Those are states reserved for experience.
东西时手里拿着一个有重量的物体，想必会让你比仅仅观看更能深刻体会到这项技能的复杂性。你认为为什么仅仅是通过某种方式让人们从脑海中抽离出来并进入身体，似乎就能提供某种针对这种过度自信的缓冲或保护？心理模拟根本不是为了结合生理反应和内在状态而建立的。那些是专属于亲身体验的状态。
So, unfortunately, we spend so much time just in a state of mental simulation. We're constantly just thinking to ourselves, what would happen if I do this, what would happen if I do that, if I move to this city, if I try it out this skill, we're constantly just simulating things. And in those simulations, we lack the bottom-up real-time experience of actually performing, of actually experiencing those events that we can only find when we jump in and try. As Ed's research suggests, watching experts is powerful because we have the sense that some of their expertise rubs off on us.
所以，不幸的是，我们花在心理模拟状态上的时间太多了。我们不断地在心里想，如果我这样做会发生什么，如果我那样做会发生什么，如果我搬到这个城市，如果我尝试这个技能会发生什么，我们一直在模拟事情。而在那些模拟中，我们缺乏实际执行、实际经历那些事件的自下而上的实时体验，而这些只有当我们真正投入并尝试时才能找到。正如埃德的研究表明的那样，观看专家之所以具有强大的力量，是因为我们有一种他们的部分专业技能会传染给我们的感觉。
Watching them creates the illusion that we can be them. To put this another way, our screens offer us a mental shortcut. Without having to learn all the difficult things that experts know, we get the feeling that we can play that beautiful piece of music or build that bondore ourselves. Watching others can also provide us with a safety net. When life gets too hard, our screens can serve up solace. Stay with us. After we posted a call for stories on living through others, a listener named John got in touch to say he wanted to talk. I am 26 years old, I'm living in Cincinnati, Ohio.
观看他们会产生一种我们能成为他们的幻觉。换句话说，我们的屏幕为我们提供了一条心理捷径。无需学习专家所知道的所有困难知识，我们就觉得自己可以演奏那首优美的乐曲，或者自己建立那种联系。观看他人也可以为我们提供一个安全网。当生活变得太艰难时，屏幕可以提供慰藉。请继续收听。在我们发出征集通过他人生活的真实故事的号召后，一位名叫约翰的听众联系了我们，说他想聊聊。我今年26岁，住在俄亥俄州辛辛那提。
Currently just a utility technician. John didn't say what he wanted to talk about. He asked that we not share his last name. John went to high school in a conservative part of Ohio. For most of those years, he didn't tell anyone that he was gay. Coming out just wasn't a thing you did in high school. He had dates, but not real ones. Mostly, he went out with friends who were girls as a way of blending in. It would just be like meeting girls on dates, just going to the high school prom or home coming.
目前只是一名公用事业技术员。约翰没有说他想聊什么。他要求我们不要透露他的姓氏。约翰在俄亥俄州一个保守的地区上高中。在那大部分时间里，他没有告诉任何人他是同性恋。在高中出柜根本不是你会做的事。他约会过，但不是真正的约会。通常情况下，他和身为女生的朋友出去玩，以此来融入群体。那就像是和女孩约会见面，只是去参加高中舞会或返校节。
That was more the main aim. There wasn't any romantic relation other than you were just kind of just friends that liked each other enough. John came out to friends in college. He wanted to date, but it was hard to figure out who was single and who was gay. So he looked for signs. I'll look at something they do. Is their hair a certain way or their fingers a certain way or do they say certain things?
那更多是主要目的。除了你们只是互相挺喜欢的普通朋友之外，并没有什么浪漫关系。约翰在大学里向朋友们出柜了。他想约会，但很难看出谁是单身，谁是同性恋。所以他寻找线索。我会观察他们的一些行为。他们的发型是不是某种特定的发型，或者手指是不是某种特定的形状，或者他们会不会说某些特定的话？
John thinks back to a guy in his engineering class sophomore year. He had long hair and red infinity tattoos on his wrists. John thought, hmm, he's cute. But it didn't go anywhere. He could never figure out if the guy was gay and he didn't have the courage to start a conversation. He still finds it hard sorting out who's gay, who's straight, who's single. That's why he turned to Grindr, the dating and hookup app. It removed all the guesswork and at first Grindr was great. His senior year, John found a familiar face on Grindr, someone he'd met his freshman year. John suggested that we call him Ryan. It's a pseudonym. Ryan looked
约翰回想起大二时工程学课上的一个男生。他留着长发，手腕上纹着红色的无限大符号纹身。约翰想，嗯，他挺可爱的。但这并没有什么进展。他永远也猜不出那个男生是不是同性恋，而他也没有勇气开启对话。他现在仍然觉得很难分清谁是同性恋，谁是异性恋，谁是单身。这就是为什么他转向了Grindr这款约会和约炮软件。它消除了所有的猜测，起初Grindr真的很棒。在大四的时候，约翰在Grindr上发现了一个熟悉的面孔，那是他在大一见过的人。约翰建议我们叫他瑞恩。这是一个化名。瑞恩看起来
like he spent a lot of time in the gym. He had a great body, blonde hair, and kind blue eyes. For two weeks, they talked through the app about their lives, about music, politics, sexuality. They clicked. You know, we had a lot to talk about, you know, and maybe we'd talk more about it in person. So John asked him, Hey, um, could I get your number? Like your actual real number, not just like, you know, and maybe we'd talk more about it in person. So John asked him, Hey, um, could I get your number, like your actual real number, not just like, you know, your Facebook or your Instagram account? Ryan said yes.
像是在健身房花了很多时间。他有着健美的身材、金色的头发和温和的蓝眼睛。两周里，他们通过软件谈论他们的生活、音乐、政治、性取向。他们很合得来。你知道，我们有很多话题可聊，而且也许我们可以当面聊更多。所以约翰问他，嘿，嗯，我能要你的电话号码吗？就像你真正的号码，而不仅仅是，你知道的，也许我们可以当面聊更多。所以约翰问他，嘿，嗯，我能要你的电话号码吗，你真正的电话号码，而不仅仅是，你知道的，你的Facebook或Instagram账号？瑞恩答应了。
They went to the movies. It was the Martian with Matt Damon. John was nervous, but he took Ryan's hand and kept it there the rest of the movie. At the end, during the credits, Ryan leaned in and gave John a long, confident kiss. They kept kissing as the credits rolled and the music played. The song was love train. John hoped this was the start of something real. Then Halloween came. It's the weekend.
他们去看电影了。那是马特·达蒙主演的《火星救援》。约翰很紧张，但他握住了瑞恩的手，并在接下来的整部电影中一直握着。最后，在演职员表滚动时，瑞恩倾身给了约翰一个漫长而自信的吻。随着演职员表滚动和音乐响起，他们一直在接吻。那首歌是《爱之列车》（Love Train）。约翰希望这是真正美好事物的开始。然后万圣节到了。那是周末，
And John finds out that Ryan has made some last-minute plans with a friend to go to Kent, Halloween. This is the annual party scene downtown around Kent State University. John asks, hey, maybe could I come, you know, and he was like, um, sure, you can come. So he makes a costume really fast. I guess I was a mix between kiss and Adam Lambert. Adam Lambert, that pop star who kind of looks like George
约翰发现瑞恩和朋友做了临时计划去肯特参加万圣节活动。那是肯特州立大学周围市中心一年一度的派对场景。约翰问，嘿，也许我可以去吗，你知道的，他的反应是，嗯，当然，你可以来。于是他飞快地制作了一个服装。我想我的造型介于KISS乐队和亚当·兰伯特之间。亚当·兰伯特，那个长相有点像乔治
Michael, but with more makeup. And so what I did was I got like a wig with a faux hawk on it and then I put on what white makeup and lipstick. So I guess I looked like a Goth Adam Lambert. That's the best way I can explain this. And he goes out to the bars by himself to wait for Ryan. He starts to drink and he starts to text. When you guys showing up to Kent Halloween, when you guys showing up to Kent Halloween,
迈克尔但妆容更浓的流行歌星。所以我做的是弄了一个莫西干假发，然后涂了白色的妆和口红。所以我想我看起来像个哥特风的亚当·兰伯特。这是我能解释的最好的方式了。他独自一人去酒吧等瑞恩。他开始喝酒，并开始发短信。你们什么时候去肯特万圣节派对？你们什么时候去肯特万圣节派对？
Ryan texts back. We'll be there in an hour. An hour goes by. No Ryan. John texts again. Ryan texts back. We'll be there in another 15 minutes. No Ryan.
瑞恩回信说。我们一小时内到。一个小时过去了。没有瑞恩的身影。约翰又发了短信。瑞恩回信说。我们再过15分钟就到。还是没有瑞恩。
So he asks again. When you guys showing up at Kent Halloween, Ryan says, we're almost on our way or something that it goes on and on like this. And as John waits and drinks, the night just gets later and later and later. It starts out at 10 o'clock. It's 10, 30, 11, 30, 12, 30, 130, and I'm just, you know, waiting around at a bar. Ryan and his friends never come.
所以他再次追问。你们什么时候到肯特万圣节派对，瑞恩说，我们快在路上了或者诸如此类的话，然后就这样一直持续下去。随着约翰一边等待一边喝酒，夜晚变得越来越深。从10点开始。10点半、11点半、12点半、1点半，而我只是，你知道的，在酒吧里闲逛等待。瑞恩和他的朋友根本没有来。
And it turns out that they went somewhere else in town to go hang out and like I wasn't really invited to go around and that was like where things just fizzled out. I mean you must be really upset and heartbroken when this happened. Oh, me I think I was. I think I I think this is my senior year and I this is like the I goes about to graduate and you know I had so much like work I had to do and like I really was, I was depressed after this. I was totally devastated. Then it got worse. Ryan broke things off with John through a text.
结果证明他们去了镇上的其他地方玩，就好像我根本没有被邀请去一样，事情也就是在那时彻底泡汤了。我的意思是，发生这种事你一定很难过和心碎。哦，我吗，我想我是的。我想我，我想正值大四，而且我这就像是快要毕业了，你知道的，我有那么多工作要做，而且我真的，这件事之后我很沮丧。我彻底崩溃了。然后情况变得更糟了。瑞恩通过一条短信和约翰分手了。
It wasn't even a text with actual words that he had written himself. He sent me like some sort of like, it was a gif. A gif, one of those tiny trivial video clips that runs in a loop. And it was basically said, I don't like you. And that was it. Oh, it's really painful, isn't it? It is very painful. And I think that's kind of set me down like, you know, other relationships. It's just kind of... It still stings a lot. And that's why I kind of really don't want. I just don't want to get hurt like that again.
甚至都不是他自己写的实际文字的短信。他发给我某种像是，那是一个动图。一个动图，那种循环播放的小巧琐碎的视频剪辑。基本上就是说，我不喜欢你。事情就是这样。哦，这真的很痛苦，不是吗？确实非常痛苦。而且我认为这在某种程度上让我对之后的其他感情产生了影响。这种刺痛感依然很强烈。这就是为什么我其实真的不想。我只是不想再受到那样的伤害了。
After Ryan, John still held out hope for Finding Love. He poured his feelings out in songs that he had recorded, including this one that he wrote and posted on Facebook, not long after Halloween. He also went back on Grindr and met other guys. But when he got sick of all the one night stands, he started to have this dim sobering thought. You're probably not going to find anybody that you like in particular. Maybe there perhaps is nobody out there that's going to really kind of click with me and I kind of, I'm
在瑞恩之后，约翰对寻找真爱仍抱有一丝希望。他把自己录制的歌曲中倾注了情感，其中包括这首他在万圣节后不久创作并发布在Facebook上的歌。他还重新登录了Grindr并遇到了其他人. 但当他对所有的约炮感到厌倦时，他开始产生这种暗淡清醒的想法。你可能找不到任何你特别喜欢的人。也许外面根本没有人能真正和我合拍，而且我某种程度上，我对现状感到
satisfied with that. Here's why John is satisfied for now. Because about four times a week, he says he pulls out his phone and escapes into another world. Where all the texts are answered, the love is required, and everyone has great abs.
满足。这就是约翰目前感到满足的原因。因为他说他大约一周有四次会拿出手机，逃进另一个世界。在那里，所有的短信都有回应，爱情是必然的，每个人都有完美的腹肌。
Where it's clear who's gay and who's not. Where people have incredible sex. I'm talking, of course, about porn. Yeah, really? Maybe. It's right there and you have like, your tips to your fingers is like, you know, all video. I don't understand, I mean, like, you do griffin'
在那里，谁是同性恋一目了然。在那里，人们拥有不可思议的性爱。当然，我指的是色情片。是的，真的吗？也许吧。它就在那里，而且只需动动指尖，你知道的，全都是视频。我不明白，我的意思是，比如，你在人类记录中进行搜寻
on the human record, it feels like. But what about college? I don't care, as long as I have you. But what about college? I don't care, as long as I have you. John says that for a lot of reasons, porn is easier than dating. For one thing, it's cheaper, it's usually free. And it feels effortless. With a boyfriend, he'd have to figure out,
，感觉像是这样。但大学怎么办？我不在乎，只要有你。但大学怎么办？我不在乎，只要有你。约翰说，出于种种原因，看色情片比约会更容易。首先，它更便宜，通常是免费的。而且感觉毫不费力。如果交了男朋友，他就必须弄清楚，
where is this going? How long will this last? Does he really like me? And then the boyfriend will start making requests like, Oh, can you also be my bank account and also help me out with chores around the house? All this stuff. It's stress and obligations he doesn't want, and he's got more urgent things to do. Like I have to, you know, build up my career right now and also pay off my loans and try
这关系会走向何方？这能持续多久？他真的喜欢我吗？然后男朋友就会开始提出要求，哦，你能不能也当我的钱包，顺便帮我分担一下家务活？所有这些事情。这是他不想要的压力和义务，而且他还有更紧急的事情要做。比如我现在必须，你知道的，建立我的事业，还要还清贷款，并努力
to figure out, do I want to buy a house or not and There's something else Unlike in a bar or on grinder the people on the screen Can't see you they don't know who you are which John feels is a good thing. I am mixed so A lot of people of color when you're on a dating app it is Harder to find people just because they can see who you are They know what you look like. You're not sure if like they don't like you because they don't like you as a person Or they don't like you because they just don't find you attractive because of your race
弄清楚，我到底想不想买房子，而且还有别的事情。不像在酒吧里或在Grindr上，屏幕上的人看不到你，他们不知道你是谁，约翰觉得这是一件好事。我是混血儿，所以很多有色人种在用约会软件时，找对象会更难，仅仅因为他们能看到你是谁。他们知道你长什么样。你不确定他们不喜欢你，是因为不喜欢你这个人，还是因为他们仅仅觉得你的种族缺乏吸引力
But then like versus porn if you if you discriminate on porn, it's not as big of an issue. With porn, nobody's dumped through a gif or left alone at a bar looking like Goth Adam Lambert. Nobody's heart gets broken. There's no kind of messiness when it comes to feelings and relationships. No feelings hurt. I mean, there probably are feelings hurt
但相比之下，如果是看色情片，如果你对色情片挑三拣四，这就不是什么大问题了。看色情片，没有人会通过动图被甩，也不会被独自留在酒吧里看起来像个哥特风的亚当·兰伯特。没有人会心碎。在感情和关系方面，没有任何一地鸡毛的混乱。也没有人受伤。我的意思是，看色情片可能也会伤害感情
with pornography, but... John's two ones real intimacy. But as he says, he's put that on a shelf. You know, we always have like dreams of becoming like rock stars and so we buy a guitar and then we play it for a while. And then after things just not working out, we just put that in the case for a while and then after things just not working out we just put that in the case for a little bit and hopefully maybe when we get more time we can go take that thing
，但是……约翰内心渴望真正的亲密关系。但正如他所说，他把那份渴望暂时搁置了。你知道，我们总是梦想成为摇滚巨星，于是我们买了一把吉他，然后弹了一段时间。然后事情不顺利，我们就把它放回琴盒里晾了一阵子，然后事情不顺利，我们就把它放回琴盒里放一小会儿，希望也许等我们有更多时间了，我们可以把那个东西
out and start playing it again. That's kind of how I feel about relationships. It's like I haven't really given up completely. I have so many problems but a relationship doesn't have to be one of them right now. When it comes to relationships, John has worked hard to be where he is today, open about his sexuality, willing to start a conversation, ready to take someone's hand in a movie theater. But for now, watching other people be intimate will have to do. Sometimes though, he does wonder about the bargain he's made, trading real people for virtual ones. I feel I've lost something but I just can't name what I've lost when I do watch
拿出来重新开始弹奏。我对感情就是这种感觉。就好像我并没有完全放弃。我有很多问题，但目前感情不一定非要成为其中之一。说到感情，约翰为了走到今天付出了很大的努力，他坦然面对自己的性取向，愿意主动开启对话，准备好在电影院里牵起某个人的手。但目前为止，看别人亲密相处只能将就一下了。不过有时，他确实会思考自己做出的这笔交易——用真实的人换取虚拟的人。我觉得我失去了某些东西，但我却说不出当我观看
for. There's something it feels like you've lost when you've kind of committed to using it as a substitute, then actually, you know, being in a relationship. I think it's a lot of it is that the empathy of it, there's no empathy in that transaction when you're on a pay for site or anything that's not real. All of us are recruits in an extraordinary uncontrolled experiment. No one has asked you if you want to be part of this experiment, and it's hard to extricate yourself. As entertainment and fantasy and the feats of experts flow into our brains through our screens and headphones, it's easier and easier to live through other people. There is no simple answer to whether vicarious living is good or bad.
时到底失去了什么。当你承诺用它作为替代品，而不是真正地，你知道的，去谈恋爱时，确实会有一种失去了某些东西的感觉。我觉得很大一部分原因是同理心，当你使用付费网站或任何不真实的东西时，那种交易中是没有同理心的。我们所有人都是一场非同寻常的失控实验中的新兵。没有人问过你想不想加入这个实验，而且你很难抽身。随着娱乐、幻想和专家的绝技通过屏幕和耳机涌入我们的大脑，通过他人生活变得越来越容易。关于间接生活是好是坏，并没有简单的答案。
Watching experts can inspire. It can also demotivate. Maybe the real question is not whether vicarious living is good or bad for you. It's whether you are actively choosing it. Being deliberate about when you turn a screen into a replacement for your life means that when the time is right, you also get to turn off that screen. This week's episode was produced by Laura Correll and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Path Shah, Thomas Liu, Kat Shuknecht and Lushik Waba. Our Ronsang hero this week is Veronica Zaragovia who recorded our interview with Natalie, our
观看专家可以带来启发。它也可能消磨动力。也许真正的问题不在于间接生活对你来说是好是坏。而在于你是否在积极地选择它。对何时将屏幕变成生活的替代品保持审慎，意味着当适时的时候，你也可以关掉那个屏幕。本期节目由劳拉·科雷尔制作，特拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特剪辑。我们的团队包括雷娜·科恩、帕斯·沙、托马斯·刘、卡特·舒克内赫特和鲁希克·瓦巴。我们这周的幕后英雄是录制了我们对来自佛罗里达州的听众娜塔莉采访的维罗妮卡·扎拉戈维亚。
listener from Florida. It was a hot day and Natalie spoke to us from her car. We asked them to turn off the air conditioning so that the hiss wouldn't come through the recording. We would chat for a few minutes, and then they'd pause to turn on the air conditioning and cool things down. Thank you Veronica for sweating the small stuff
那天天气很热，娜塔莉在车里接受了我们的采访。我们请他们关掉空调，这样杂音就不会被录进去了。我们聊了几分钟，然后他们就会暂停，打开空调降温。谢谢维罗妮卡关注这些细节，
and helping our shows sound great. If you liked this episode, please consider sharing it with a friend and help them to subscribe to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并帮助我们的节目呈现出美妙的音质。如果你喜欢这期节目，请考虑把它分享给朋友，并帮助他们订阅Hidden Brain。我是香卡·韦丹坦，这里是NPR。这期节目暂时还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。